oh my God
scenes like this are an everyday routine
on the outskirts of New Delhi dozens of
laborers come to the street every
morning to find work they fix their
wages with recruiters and head to the
work site most of them are hired in
construction
says he holds a master's degree but was
forced to leave his village because his
job doesn't pay enough
it's very competitive they aren't enough
jobs there are few government jobs and
private companies don't pay well it's
also difficult for us to get paid on
time
the government should fix a minimum wage
for daily wage workers like us
for jobs unemployment s or to its
highest level in 16 months urban areas
are most affected with one in 10 people
out of work fears of a global recession
are further impacting the economy
exports have dropped in recent months
Industries like manufacturing and
Technology are hiring fewer workers
projected to grow above six percent
India Remains the fastest growing
economy in the world but this growth has
disproportionately benefited the
wealthiest and the pandemic has deepened
inequality according to the latest Oxfam
report the richest one percent hold 40
percent of the wealth
the Finance Minister has announced the
Lost government budget ahead of national
elections next year in it the government
says it will spend more than 100 billion
dollars to improve infrastructure and
create jobs current Year's economic
growth is estimated to be at seven
percent
it is notable that this is the highest
among all the major economies
this is in spite of the massive slowdown
globally cost by covid-19 and a war GDP
some economists say the government
should focus on manufacturing to make
growth more inclusive any country before
us they haven't taken off they haven't
moved from agriculture to Services
directly they've gone through
Agriculture and Manufacturing
manufacturing is that platform it's that
prop which help countries get in through
middle income status and then to higher
income status
the economy is projected to bounce back
in 2024 but that's a long way off for
Millions here who are struggling to get
by now Al Jazeera New Delhi